you
ok let's try it again my goodness it's
4:30 a.m. it's 4:30 a.m. alright this
might be one of the last ones here hmm
we have been here before and in the game
it played bishop here it's not doing
that now let's try this can I get rid of
that to LightSquared bishop I could
let's take and return home if I do this
I'm too afraid of that advance so I have
the structure I'm looking for let's
reinforce it you might play this get rid
of that night
hmm
let's do that
okay and give him a kick all righty now
I am ready to maybe do something
dangerous let's start with this though
the thing I have in mind is c5 and then
this oh so much for that
this is the one piece I didn't want to
have exchanged I wanted to put I wanted
to have still the possibility for like a
good night versus a bad Bishop or a good
versus bad Bishop if I enter like a if I
have a good versus a good versus bad
Bishop position against the computer it
usually miss plays it I've won endgame
positions where I was down upon and it
gives a pond back and then gives up a
good King position things like that so I
think Knight geez
I guess do that ooh
pon pushed night here
you bet that'll happen pond push you
will not see a clean trade night here
exploiting the pin we need to get my
night doing something Oh Queen trade
mmm
I'd really like a queen trade see if it
goes for that nope okay this was my idea
to kick the queen out of there oh boy
I'm in trouble big trouble
oh yeah if I take like this night here
to d6 so eventually I have to take like
this go up starting to yawn pon takes C
takes D like b5 I think I should kick
the Queen out of here first let's give
it a shot okay
I'll take like this Shack huh
what is that even doing I wasn't
expecting that
soon
Queen block what am I missing
edit 33 Wow
really mmm
nightly 7 to defend this hmm actually 97
rooks see - ouch Queen takes Queen
Knight takes Queen threatens a fork
threatens entry here if I Castle the
Queen takes Knight takes rook here white
is going to be entering not much I can
do about it I think this is gone Oh too
weak too slow and tired too weak too
slow ok boy
how to make a move though let's go with
this
I want to give up a pond at the end of
that I would have been on e5 dropping
this dropping that pond 30 seconds is
not a lot uh I gotta go quicker
I gotta go quicker trade please get rid
of that night uh oh that's a killer that
is a killer
yeah there's no hope here tricky night
passed pond that one's done okay I'll
resign that
you